blier qui permet d'attaquer les lois
l'autre instrument c'est l'initiative
populaire qui permet d'introduire un
nouvel article de la constitution suite
même que un sujet arrive en votation
signifie qu' un problème ce qui oblige
les les partenaires politiques à se
remettre autour de la table bastien ne
pourrait pas y avoir de dérive populiste
vrai que leurs proches ne risque de la
voir les votations sur des sujets dits
populiste
mais je pense malgré tout que le
meilleur moyen pour lui de populis est
précisément d'en discuter et de trancher
[Musique]
près de deux cent quinze mille
manifestants contre le passage à
lithaire aujourd'hui dans toute la
france selon le ministère de l'intérieur
une mobilisation en baisse par rapport
au chiffre de samedi dernier chez à 19
heures autorités ont recensé 217 actions
interpellation et un blessé parmi les
forces de l'ordre
en afghanistan les taliban sont aux
portes de kaboul et viennent de
s'emparer d'une nouvelle capitale de
province est le président afghan affirme
tout mettre en oeuvre pour trouver une
solution politique pour la paix la
stabilité à de nombreux pays occidentaux
se préparent à fermer leur ambassade et
à évacuer leurs diplomates
l'armée s'est déployée dans les
stations-service au liban le pays est en
ce moment au croît de graves pénuries de
carburant une décision à ce prise suite
à celle du gouverneur de la banque
centrale qui a levé mercredi les
subventions sur l'importation de
plusieurs
elle le liban qui traverse depuis à 2019
la pire crise économique de son histoire
[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
si vous nous rejoignez sur rt france on
lisait dans les titres de ce journal
près de 215 milles manifestons
aujourd'hui dans toute la france contre
le pass sanitaire selon le ministère de
l'intérieur elle soit un peu moins que
lors du rassemblement organisé la
semaine dernière à plus de 200 actions
ont été menées aujourd'hui dans tout le
pays à paris trois manifestations
étaient organisées regroupant à près de
14000 personnes ont fait le point
justement avec notre reporter guy marosi
qui a suivi le cortège organisé par les
gilet jaune
ce sont plusieurs milliers de personnes
qui ont répondu présent à cet appel des
gilet jaune ils sont partis de la porte
dorée dans le 12e arrondissement de la
capitale pour terminer ici place de
clichy un tracé de plus de 10 kilomètres
au cours duquel ont été entendues les
fameux slogan maintenant bien connue des
gilet jaune depuis près de trois ans
depuis le début de ce mouvement mais ce
qui a été le plus souvent scandé au sein
de ce cortège et bien c'est le mot
liberté liberté asséné presque sans
interruption depuis le départ de la
manifestation car pour les personnes qui
ont participé à ce cortège qui défilait
contre le pass sanitaire contre
l'obligation vaccinale est bien ces
mesures représentent et bien une
atteinte aux libertés ne parle pas
sanitaire le gouvernement a rendu une
vaccination obligatoire de fait donc je
suis là pour défendre
la liberté de ce versement à signer ou
pas parce que c'est une liberté publique
que le conseil constitionnel
malheureusement à piétiner je suis aussi
là pour défendre la liberté de circuler
la liberté de travail et la liberté de
déplacer la liberté de distraire ce sont
des libertés fondamentales
voilà qu'il faut respecter dans le pays
et que malheureusement comme je ne le
dira le conseil constitutionnel a écarté
de sa décision puisqu'il a validé le
pass sanitaires donc la cour
constitutionnelle a cru pouvoir valider
une loi abusivement qui est le pass
sanitaire qui est un viol deux de nos
lois
inaliénables et sacrés de l'homme et
qui est à mon sens le contraire de ce
que veut la république c'est-à-dire un
principe d'égalité la mobilisation s'est
tout de même déroulée dans le calme et
sans aucun débordement et même si les
manifestants étaient particulièrement
remontés il faut dire qu'aujourd'hui est
le premier samedi depuis l'extension du
pass sanitaire au bar et au restaurant
et qui succède à un nouveau tour de vis
sanitaire annoncé il ya quelques jours
par le gouvernement concernant
l'application de ce fameux pass
sanitaires aux centres commerciaux de
plus de 20 mille mètres carrés dans
certains départements une nouvelle
mesure qui a peu de chances d'apaiser
les esprits mais écoutez justement les
réactions de jean marc flipo
porte-parole debout la france et à
françois à cravans fils médecin
spécialiste de santé publique
parce que l'on constate c'est que vous
avez des personnes de toute extraction
sociale de toutes origines qui
manifestent parce que elles se sentent
visés directement par les propos du
président de la république qui les
rendent responsables de la situation et
tout le monde a constaté que ce pass
sanitaire est une grave atteinte à des
droits fondamentaux
naturel constitutionnel et
imprescriptible de citoyens tout le
monde content du tout le monde c'est le
conseil d'état conseil constitutionnel
la connaissance paritaire la cnil tous
les organismes qui ont été consultés
dans l'élaboration se croisent helmand
ont tous fait ce même constat ils ont
simplement considéré que le projet doit
présenter des exigences de santé
publique qui allait au dessus de tout ça
et je suis désolé mais ça ne passe pas
nous nous sommes en profond désaccord
avec ça nous estimons que les valeurs
cardinales de la république que sont la
liberté l'égalité la fraternité sont au
dessus de tout le reste est que toutes
les lois doivent se plier à cette
exigence
cette exigence là d'autant plus
qu'aujourd'hui on se rend compte que
l'objectif du gouvernement de parvenir à
une immunité collective s'éloigne de
plus en plus voilà aujourd'hui
l'objectif et ça je pense que j'espère
en tout cas que même les manifestants
partage c'est de sauver des vies c'est
de sortir de la crise de retrouver une
vie normale là tout ce qu'on peut dire
c'est que la vaccination c'est le
meilleur outil qu'on a sur le plan
sanitaire pour sortir de la crise qu'ils
aient besoin quelque part de se passer
ni terre pour pousser un peu la
vaccination et d'autre part à côté
continuer à faire tourner l'économie qui
est aussi un facteur de santé
extrêmement important à plus long terme
les vaccinations continue espérons que
dans un mois dans deux mois et bien on
est plus besoin du passé ni terre qui
est suffisamment de vacciner que les
chiffres baissent que le voilà et que la
tensions hospitalières diminue et dans
ce cas d'accord sur le plan de la
liberté c'est beaucoup l'ont déjà dit
mais où jusqu'où va la liberté
individuelle et la responsabilité d'une
personne qui ait infecté qui refusent de
se faire vacciner qui je sais pas
rentrer dans un ehpad et puis créer un
cluster ou et sa part de responsabilité
donc là sur plan sanitaire il ya un vrai
débat voilà moi je pense qu'il faut tout
de même se dire qu'il ya une part de
protection qui est importante c'est
qu'il faut garder en tête impasse
sanitaires pour ralentir la propagation
du virus selon le gouvernement et ainsi
s'éviter situation hospitalière en
martinique ou moins d'un adulte sur cinq
et vacciné les contaminations et les
hospitalisations grimpe en flèche
elle et soignons sur place parlent de
médecine de catastrophe les morgues sont
pleines
l'inquiétude grandit de jour en jour
pierre jan mazari
un hôpital à bout de souffle face à
l'afflux massif de nouveaux patients le
chu de fort de france se retrouve saturé
en particulier dans son service de
réanimation
on n'a pas les moyens aujourd'hui de
prendre tout le monde
et on n'aura pas les moyens quoi qu'on
fasse si à un moment
les mesures qui ont été prises diminue
pas le nombre de patients cet hôpital il
n'a pas été fait pour soigner autant de
patients en aussi peu de temps vraiment
on est
submergé on peut le dire je pense que
c'est bon pour soigner les quelque 250
patients atteints du coronavirus c'est
désormais l'ensemble de l'établissement
qui se consacre à la lutte contre le coc
vide 19 les opérations sont reportés la
consommation en oxygène été multipliée
par six mais les malades arrivent chaque
jour un peu plus nombreux conséquence
l'hôpital connaît une mortalité sans
précédent et sa morgue déborder doit
faire appel aux pompes funèbres privé
pour recueillir les corps
grâce aux efforts des pompes funèbres et
vous voyez là aujourd'hui ils sont en
ont donc c'est grâce à rue on a un flux
qui arrivent mais eux ils voient pas
rapidement avec et c'est grâce à lui
qu'on arrive à tenir le rythme jusqu'à
maintenant donc au départ on a eu
beaucoup de patients de plus de 70 ans
et maintenant on a beaucoup de patients
à de tout âge de 20 ans de cinq ans de
40 ans pour tenter de soulager le chu
l'armée à doubler la capacité d'accueil
de son hôpital de campagne désormais
porté à 20 lits un avion doit également
évacué aujourd'hui six patients vers la
métropole
mais la situation sanitaire maintenant
en russie si le nombre de contaminations
commencé à diminuer le taux de mortalité
lui c'est reste élevé si les
explications justement avec à notre
correspondante à moscou vers un nordmann
819 mort du coronavirus la russie
renouvelle en cause fois son record de
décès hier le chiffre était à la hauteur
de 815 avant-hier 808 personnes décédées
à moscow l'épicentre de l'épidémie en
russie les autorités expliquent le
niveau élevé de mortalité par la
propagation du variant delta ii
coronavirus ainsi que la chaleur
anormale qui règne depuis deux mois dans
la région écoutez cette dynamique est
liée à la forte augmentation de
l'incidence de l'infection due à la
propagation d'un nouveau variant de
coronavirus en juin ainsi qu'à la météo
anormalement chaudes dans la ville ces
derniers mois la chaleur anormale a
affecté négativement la gravité de
l'évolution de la maladie chez les
personnes infectées par le coronavirus
comme ses conséquences et a conduit à
une aggravation en premier lieu des
maladies du système cardiovasculaire le
taux de mortalité dû coronavirus à
moscou au premier round 2021 est le
suivant
2,93 % si l'on ne tient compte que des
cas où le coronavirus était la cause
principale
3,95 % si l'on tient compte de tous les
cas où le co vide était la maladie
principale ou concomitante selon les
autorités sanitaires de la capitale les
taux de mortalité sont en retard de
quelques semaines par rapport au pic de
k2 coronavirus les chiffres record de
contamination à mouscron était
enregistrée en juin 2021 lorsque le
nombre quotidien de nouveaux cadres de
coronavirus était à plus de 9000 la
russie recense plus de vingt deux mille
nouveaux cas de coronavirus chaque jour
dont près de 2000 à moscou la baisse des
contaminations des hospitalisations a
conduit hier le maire de la capitale a
levé une série de restrictions
sanitaires dans la ville et des enfants
les décès d'enfants dûs aux copies 19 de
plus en plus nombreux en indonésie la
situation est particulièrement
préoccupante à plus de 1200 enfants sont
morts depuis le début de la pandémie et
dont la moitié sont des nourrissons un
drame qui s'explique entre autres par
des problèmes de malnutrition le manque
de soins et un taux de vaccination très
faible anthologie
dans un cimetière bondée les sépultures
récente ne cessent d'apparaître des
tombeaux miniature pour accueillir les
nouvelles victimes du coronavirus des
enfants est de plus en plus souvent des
nouveau nés
certains de nos proches vivent à
proximité alors un par un ils sont venus
rendre visite à notre bébé ever environ
une semaine après mon mari a eu de la
fièvre et de la toux
je suis allé voir un médecin est celui
ci m'a demandé de faire un test de
dépistage kobe 19 et le résultat était
positif
[Musique]
alors que le virus circule encore
énormément en indonésie avec près de
30000 contamination par jour
le système de santé largement défaillant
ne permet pas de prendre correctement
charge tous les patients
après que beverly a été testée positive
au coït 19 le médecin a conseillé à
beverly de se faire soigner
immédiatement dans un hôpital doté d'une
unité de soins intensifs néonatals nous
avons cherché des hôpitaux de 10h à 18h
mais tous les hôpitaux de jakarta était
complet il ne pouvait pas prendre mon
bébé car il était déjà débordés
tous les services d'urgence avaient
dépassé leurs capacités trop de patients
sur les 270 millions d'habitants que
compte le pays moins de 10% de la
population est totalement vacciner et
pour enrayer ce funeste phénomène les
professionnels ont courage des adultes à
se faire vacciner mais aussi les enfants
les personnes les plus proches des
enfants sont leurs familles nous devons
donc veiller à ce que les parents soient
protégés par des vaccins premièrement
car ce sont eux qui sont les plus
mobiles et qui sont le plus exposés au
virus si les parents sont infectés ils
risquent fort de contaminer leurs
enfants
les services de santé ayant été
perturbée la question se pose de savoir
si les enfants peuvent encore faire
valoir leurs droits aux vaccinations de
routine et aux autres services de santé
si ces droits ne sont pas respectés les
enfants courent un plus grand risque
d'infection et donc de décès
depuis le début de la pandémie quatre
cent mille enfants indonésiens de moins
de 17 ans ont été contaminés et plus de
1200 sont décédées selon l'association
nationale des pédiatres et les ong save
the children une augmentation des cas de
contamination chez les enfants qui ne se
limite pas à l'indonésie le nombre de
cas graves restent très rares mais des
médecins américains israéliens ou
français s'inquiètent d'accueillir dans
leurs hôpitaux des patients de plus en
plus jeunes
l'inquiétude qui monte en afghanistan où
les talibans sont actuellement aux
portes de kaboul et viennent de son
pareil d'une nouvelle capitale de
provence dans le nord du pays elle si le
président afghan on tente de rassurer de
trouver une solution politique à la
crise est les talibans eux ne cesse
d'avancer à la communauté internationale
s'inquiète aussi et certains pays
décident même de fermer leurs ambassades
et d'évacuer leurs diplomates cyrielle
benavides bullion
les experts américains donné un mois aux
talibans avant de faire tomber kaboul
leur sinistre prédictions pourrait se
réaliser plus tôt que prévu vendredi les
insurgés ont pris le contrôle de poule
et à l'âme à seulement 50 km de la
capitale
lors d'une adresse de la nation le
président afghan ashraf ghani tente de
rassurer la population et annonce des
consultations pour mettre fin à la
guerre
comme je le sais vous êtes préoccupé par
votre présence et votre avenir je peux
vous assurer qu'en tant que président
mon objectif sera d'éviter
l'augmentation de la stabilité de la
violence et du déplacement de mon peuple
auch au nahd
marc thomas et la hougue hélico
c'est pourquoi j'ai entamé de vastes
consultations au sein du gouvernement
avec les anciens et dirigeants
politiques les représentants du peuple
et des partenaires internationaux
la consultation se poursuit rapidement à
cet égard et les résultats seront
partagés avec les citoyens très bientôt
ce vendredi à kaboul les forces de
sécurité sont présentes en nombre dans
les rues de la capitale mais les
habitants sont inquiets
nous avons peur des talibans car les
capitales tombe tout jour après jour
kaboul pourrait aussi tomber sous peu
quand les dernières villes seront
capturés les frontières seront bloqués
et les prix de la nourriture et des
biens augmenteront
c'est sûr que cela nous affecte les gens
sont déjà très pauvres ici
nous avons peur pourquoi n'y at il pas
de soutien armé pour nous forces de
l'ordre pourquoi ne sont ils pas soutenu
pendant les combats pourquoi leurs
familles ont elles faim et leurs
salaires n'est-il pas versée ils sont
sacrifiés en première ligne ils doivent
battre en retraite ou abandonnés parce
qu'il manque d'équipement le départ des
américains est irresponsable la personne
qui est en charge qui est dans le palais
présidentiel qui est le président de
l'amérique ce n'est pas une bonne
personne il est nuisible pour l'amérique
et à 100% pour l'afghanistan une
situation alarmante déplorée par la
communauté internationale qui appelle
les talibans à de la retenue ainsi qu'à
respecter le droit humanitaire
international
la poursuite des conflits urbains se
traduira par un carnage continue dont
les civils paieront le prix le plus
élevé
j'appelle toutes les parties à prendre
conscience du lourd bilan du conflit et
de son impact dévastateur sur les civils
dirigé des attaques contre des civils
est une violation grave du droit
humanitaire international et constitue
un crime de guerre
j'appelle les talibans à cesser
immédiatement leurs offensives et à
négocier de bonne foi dans l'intérêt de
l'afghanistan et de son peuple
j'espère que les discussions à doha au
qatar entre les représentants de la
république islamique d'afghanistan et
les talibans soutenus par la région et
la communauté internationale au sens
large permettront de retrouver la
meilleure voie vers un règlement négocié
du conflit
des négociations durant lesquelles le
gouvernement afghan a proposé aux
talibans de partager le pouvoir une
proposition restée sans réponse jusqu'à
présent vendredi l'ambassade des
etats-unis à kaboul a ordonné à son
personnel de détruire des documents
sensibles et des symboles américains qui
pourraient être utilisés par les
talibans à des fins de propagande
désordre annonciateur d'un départ
imminent pour les forces occidentales et
d'une afghanistan désormais livret a
même
mais quelles perspectives pour la galice
t'envoyer justement l'analyse du
géopolitologue david haye a rigolé rose
rédacteur en chef de la revue orior
stratégique on a vu que la stratégie de
communication des talibans étaient
étaient fortement axées sus te ment sur
7 la clé la question de leur crédibilité
vis-à-vis de l'international ce soit
vis-à-vis des russes des chinois et donc
de ce qu'on appelle nous la colle aux
métiers internationale ce qui est un peu
différent par rapport à la situation des
années 90 où manifestement à l'époque
c'était le cadet de leurs soucis c'est
pas le cas aujourd'hui et donc c'est le
seul moyen de pression relatif qui
demeure joseph boire elle a dit le
représentant justement de de bruxelles
des européens a dit que si si il y avait
une prise par la force et s'il y'avait
l'établissement de de la charia comme on
peut le craindre ça hypothèque ray toute
forme de reconnaissance si les taliban
parvenait à prendre le contrôle de tout
le pays c'est je dirais que c'est là le
seul la seule carte mais le problème
c'est que ces relative parce que les
talibans joue aussi sur les divisions
les membres du conseil de sécurité ils
ont discuté avec les russes d'un côté et
surtout les chinois de l'autre et ils
savent très bien instrumentaliser les
divisions de cette communauté
internationale heures profit
des fields libanaise devant les stations
essence des camions de carburant pris
d'assaut par la population et une armée
qui me lasse de distribuer gratuitement
les stocks un scénario qui montre
l'étendue de la misère qui a gagné le
pays tout entier la banque du liban
refus de rétablir les subventions sur le
carburant elle tant que le gouvernement
ne se réunit par amaya sous blair
une armée mobilisée et qui prêtent main
forte à la population depuis plusieurs
jours les libanais bloquent les routes
du pays pour protester contre
l'augmentation des prix du carburant
et ont pris d'assaut ce samedi de
nombreuses stations essence pour aider
la population face à la crise
les soldats distribuent les stocks
gratuitement aux habitants
chaque jour je dois aller me faire une
piqûre à l'hôpital j'ai la sclérose en
plaques l'armée m'a fait de plan et
maintenant c'est bon ils m'ont aussi
remplir un bidon d'essence
une inquiétude supplémentaire pour les
hôpitaux et les commerçants qui doivent
alimenter leurs générateurs électriques
et ne peuvent plus se fournir en diesel
nous sommes les seuls qui restent les
grandes boulangeries ont cessé
d'apporter du pain dans le quartier donc
la pression est sur nous en raison de
notre petite production nous n'avons
reçu que 36 tonnes de farine
subventionnée
donc si la crise persiste nous ne
tiendrons pas plus d'une semaine et je
ne sais pas quoi faire et je travaille
avec tout ce que j'ai je ne cache pas un
grain de farine
riad salamé gouverneur de la banque du
liban se défend de cette décision et
assume sa position en pointant du doigt
l'irresponsabilité de l'état lorsque les
réserves obligatoires à la banque du
liban atteignent une ligne rouge
la banque du liban n'a d'autre choix que
d'arrêter le financement des
importations de carburant tous les
responsables libanais est au courant de
la décision de lever les subventions à
commencer par la présidence de la
république en passant par le
gouvernement sans oublier le conseil
supérieur de défense qu'ils aillent au
parlement et qu'ils votent la loi au
lieu de jouer la comédie le gouvernement
en effet la possibilité d'adopter une
loi qui autorise la banque du liban à
puiser dans les réserves du pays
le gouverneur de la banque appelle
également à la formation d'un
gouvernement
afin de pouvoir entamer les réformes qui
pourront venir à bout d'une crise
économique qui s'enlise
alors que la livre libanaise connaît une
dévaluation sans précédent de 90 % de sa
valeur les libanais dépense désormais
cinq fois leur salaire pour l'achat des
denrées alimentaires
à cette détresse économique s'ajoute un
manque de médicaments et de nombreux
produits de première nécessité dans un
contexte de crise sanitaire qui voit une
résurgence des cas de kovy 19
en algérie maintenant des feux de forêt
sont quasiment sous contrôle des
incendies meurtriers avec un bilan
humain particulièrement lourd au moins
90 décès c'est le nord du pays et
principalement la kabylie qui a été
ravagé par les flammes l élan de
solidarité pour venir en aide à la
population a été chaud au coeur du
dispositif de secours
on a vraiment bouleversée ouais je
n'arrive pas à croire qu'on est vraiment
ici aujourd'hui en train de vous parler
qu'on est vivant vu la situation qu'on a
vécu c'est vraiment un drame c'est
vraiment c'est des situations que je
n'ai jamais vécu de toute ma vie les
algériens sont debout sont toujours là
et ils sont prêts à aider tout le monde
déplacer je suis fière d'être algérienne
je suis fier d'être qu'avant
c'était un incendie comme j'en ai jamais
vu avant
le feu d'avancé pas doucement c'était
des rafales
on ne pouvait même pas rester devant
nous étions tout de suite asphyxiés
et puis la turquie elle aussi luttent
contre les flammes en ce moment dans le
sud du pays et c'est dans ce cadre que
le ministère russe de la défense a
indiqué qu'un avion bombardier d'eau
elle s'est écrasée ça aujourd'hui
en turquie aucun survivant a parmi les
huit membres d'équipage a pas remis à
cinq militaires russes et trois
militaires turcs
[Musique]
en haïti ont maintenant un puissant
séisme a frappé l'île ce samedi le bilan
fait état d'au moins 29 morts selon le
directeur de la protection civile du
pays sur ce total dix sept morts ont été
recensés elle dans l'est dans le
département de la grande anse neuf dans
la ville de kayes et trois dans le
département des nippes où se trouve
l'épicentre du séisme dans le sud ouest
de l'île
effondrement du pont autoroutier mauron
10 de jeunes c'était il ya trois ans
jour pour jour bilan 43 morts un drame
qui a mis en lumière a le mauvais état
des infrastructures et un déficit
chronique d'entretien et
d'investissement
une soixantaine de personnes sont
poursuivies par la justice italienne
françois tessier beach
sur ces images de vidéosurveillance un
amas de débris s'effondre quelques
secondes plus tard un homme court à
travers les décombres à 11h36 ce mardi
14 août à gênes un tronçon d'environ 250
mètres du pont morand dit traversé par
l'autoroute a10 s'écroule emportant avec
lui 38 véhicules dont trois camions
je me souviens que la route s'effondrer
j'étais en train de traverser j'ai
entendu un bruit assourdissant
j'ai vu la route tomber je tombais avec
elle j'ai pensé au pire
pendant plusieurs jours
les secours tentent de retrouver
d'éventuels survivants
au total 43 personnes sont mortes et 16
sont blessés
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dix mois plus tard le pont est démolie à
l'explosif pour laisser place au nouveau
viaduc jane saint georges inaugurée le 3
août 2020 soit deux ans presque jour
pour jour après la catastrophe
le mérite revient donc à une équipe
l'équipe italienne qui a travaillé avec
compétence ténacité
confiance animé par la nécessité de
réagir à la tragédie est de reconstruire
une oeuvre qui pourrait aussi prendre la
valeur d'une rédemption
le pont que nous inaugurons aujourd'hui
est le résultat de cette force d'esprit
de la volonté de recomposer ce qui a été
brisée mais aussi de compétences et de
talents
gène doit repartir de zéro et elle le
fait d'ici
en avril dernier les conclusions de
l'enquêté du parquet italien accable
gestionnaire du pont morand dit
autostrade et pearl italia et la société
d'ingénierie spie à deux sociétés
filiales d'atlantia qui contrôlait à
l'époque les autoroutes italiennes
entre l'inauguration du pont en 1967 et
l'effondrement
donc pendant 51 ans il n'a pas été
procédé aux interventions de maintenance
minimale pour renforcer les haubans du
pilier numéro 9 qui s'est affaissé ce
jour là autre révélation des magistrats
le concessionnaire privé a financé
depuis une quarantaine d'années moins de
2% des 24 millions d'euros consacrée aux
interventions sur la structure du viaduc
tandis que les contrôles de sécurité au
fil des années sur le pont ont été jugés
lacunaire et inadéquate le 25 juin
dernier le parquet italien a demandé le
renvoi devant un tribunal de 59
personnes mises en cause dans l' enquête
la plupart sont cadres et techniciens
des société autostrade et pearl italia
spa toutes deux également poursuivi le
groupe autoroutes d'atlantia à lui sous
pression du gouvernement cédé il ya
quelques semaines sa part dans les
autoroutes italiennes un consortium
public
voilà c'est la fin de ce journal merci à
vous d'avoir suivi prochain point sur
l'actualité ce sera donc un peu plus de
30 minutes restez avec nous sur rt
france à tout à l'heure
[Musique]
nora lakehal a été la première femme à
intégrer le groupe islamisme radical de
la saur c'est l'élite des renseignements
généraux de la police française et
c'était après les attentats du 11
septembre
et quand on vient vous voir et qu'on
vous dit écoutez vous avez de la
première femme qui allait rentrer dans
ce service vous ne pouvez absolument pas
refusé votre mission première est celle
de traquer ces terroristes ce prêcheur
salafistes il vous a des tranchées pour
reprendre un code policiers il vous a
reconnu que c'est fini pour moi est ce
que ça remet en armes tout est passé
dans ma tête est ce que vous avez appris
de ces profils qu'est-ce qu'ils vont
chercher d'ailleurs dans la religion le
profil vient toujours de la misère
sociale
quand on écoute comme ça dit malheur
mais quel est le rapport avec la
radiation mais c'est la radicalisation
il faut que nous reprenions la place
dans le cerveau des enfants et de la
jeunesse